and away we go and tim diller corbin
burns big strikeout numbers doesn't
qualify for the era leaders yet that
could change tonight four innings away
and then we can
get him logged in there with that era
but
he was good he was good last time out
and he throws it away so trying to keep
wade close instead he bounces it off
that sidewall and karim's back to colton
wong but that's a free base for the
giants lamont wade
in scoring position
rowdy toles saying that that was his bad
he's popped 18 homers this year ops near
900 and a swing of the miss he got him
nicely done
burns gives up a leadoff single there
was an error but he strikes out crawford
on a chain job logan 24 old right hander
making his 15th start of the year five
and three with a 3.33
era
one two one got him swinging with the
change up so that's how webb's
evening starts one away to do that over
the course of that many innings
is just really impressive
rollover ground ball teles got the nice
hands
hits burns on the move for the second
out
and five in a row retired for burns
after the lead-off single by wade oh and
two two outs here in the second
down he goes barry that one i mean that
was a cutter clinic
he hasn't had the mvp year that he did
but he's still a solid player
3-2
that is straight three call escobar
thought it was ball four
bobby garcia now with one away here's
the 3-2 garcia leans down on one sends
it deep that ball's got a chance hey
it's gone
oh the strength of avi garcia
fooled on the pitch
never mind he barreled it up
19th home run of the season it's one
nothing brewers speaking of seven pitch
home runs
into the gap left center field got some
carry that one is off the top of the
wall
takes a big bounce
to les in the second base
he is quickly becoming a fan favorite
rowdy teles and the rowdy chants are
starting up early here tonight
got him to chase so the strikeout for
logan webb after all that just the one
run
one-nothing brewers through two
everything logan webb throws moves
two-seam fastball good change up good
slider there's the slider and it's a rip
into left to base it
third hit of the game for the brewers it
comes from willie adams with one out
[Applause]
oh two
got the ground ball the stella
will get the out at first no chance for
a double play on that one that was just
a good play
by tommy la stella to keep it from going
into right field yeah tommy did make a
really nice play gets the safe out of
first base for a nice second out of this
inning
you can afford to make some mistakes if
you're burned especially burns
especially if you have some movement
with the pitch
don't throw it again though
broken bat roller domes kicked it right
off the heel of his glove
and he had plenty of time with posey as
the runner and the giants will take it a
base runner to start the fourth
it's not like houston or arizona or
texas you can't cool it off so it gets
at his hottest look at that shattered
the bat
just a
boring in cutter that yustrimsky
breaks his bat with
[Applause]
got him to chase that slider for strike
three
that's a great pitch right there and i
just i mentioned that you doesn't mean
you can't throw the slider to garcia
because that's how the game plan is
against him you get him to chase with
sliders off the plate but two sacramento
guys going head-to-head here one from
that elk grove high school baseball
factory two-two
teles to center field
yostremski all the way back and he'll
leap and make the catch and then crash
into the wall and hopefully he's okay
he held on to the ball mike yostremski
made an amazing catch
i don't know
he does get up
paul smoked off the bat what a great
play by
ostremski going back on that ball and
then making
the jump right at the wall
sacrificing his body knowing he's going
to hit the ball wall hard and does
i guess it's a good sign that he got up
oh my goodness
what a catch
amazing catching that elbow you see the
elbow kind of jam into the wall and that
jams the shoulder as a result
i feel like you should throw a couple
before you start
start pitching again look at the elbow
wow scrape that up
so you want to play center field if you
don't practice that you know cracks that
a lot hey uh in case there's a curveball
up this is what you do
it's a genuine reaction right there
one and two the count burns not messing
around strikes him out with a slider and
that will end the inning three up three
down frame to the bottom of the order
logan webb
has found a better rhythm now in this
game
he gets another strikeout that's his
sixth tonight
yeah i'd say so and that slider has been
that big pitch for him when he has found
his rhythm
2-2 and he struck him out swinging with
the high fastball
so a very good inning for logan webb
running to the count see what he has in
mind
and that curveball he got a nice block
by narvaez he'll secure it at first for
the strikeout hammer of thor
going one to belt he had missed right
about six weeks until coming back
yesterday off the injured list
that one pulled to deep right field
garcia is going to watch it and it is
gone tie game
brandon belt his 12th home run of the
year it's one to one well that was the
fourth pitch he saw of the game in his
third at bat which is very unbrand and
belt-like but
he didn't miss that one
been the most stressful inning for burns
yet giants had tied it and they
threatened to take the lead in the sixth
and a bouncing ball to the goal glover
wall he's got it inning over burns
gets through the sixth there's a big
inning for logan webb facing the meat of
their order the team just scores you a
run
slider struck him out swinging
change up got him swinging
nine strikeouts in six innings for logan
webb
giants have the momentum in this game
one to one to score a couple of lefties
coming up
in the top of that giants lineup
a swing at a miss he struck him out
burns dials it in one two three seventh
is best-selling yet one-one game stretch
time at american family field
he hits that one hard at a diving stab
by bryant he throws him out at first
what a play chris bryant
wow
and guess who's coming up second in the
ninth inning for the giants yeah number
23 in a 1-1 ball game
and rowdy teles
you can hear the chance
lefty on lefty game on the line 1-2
pitch to
last and this is gonna win it for the
brute crew
the legend of rowdy continues
and the brewers with a walk-off win
against the giants on a friday night
you